so here we are I'm at home as I'm sure
many of you are - and we've all begun to
understand how our relationship with
ourselves with each other and the spaces
we existing can deeply impact our sense
of identity and purpose so much has
dramatically changed there's a sense of
distance now unlike ever before but what
if I told you that you could find a way
from your heart to your hand to
reconnect again and that through this
practice and embrace in this pause I
could help you to recalibrate your mind
so that you could explore this new
reality with joy enthusiasm imagination
and hope and all it would take is a
simple pen to get you there let's go
back to the beginning as a kid growing
up in a council state in southeast
London I was an outsider I'm the oldest
of six kids all of my siblings are very
English blond hair blue eyes very cute
and then there was me half Nigerian
Brown with an afro so what happens when
you look different and you feel
different and in many ways start to
think differently from everyone and
everything around you how do you find
your way out of a dark racist homophobic
and very lonely place this is where the
pen comes in I started to draw so as you
can see I've got this pen and it knows
where it's going and I've learned very
well how to follow it and the first
thing I did is I followed this line and
I drew myself out of a culture that was
only telling me what I couldn't do
I trusted my pen and it led me to
Central Saint Martin's
a very fancy art school in London where
I graduated top of my year however I
soon realized there wasn't a place for
me in London because wherever you wish -
believe it or not England is still
tree that is rooted and functions within
the class system and as a young black
gay female artist from a working-class
family I didn't stand the chance so I
left London and I moved to Japan where I
didn't experience people asking me where
I was really from I was just another
gaijin which ironically means outsider I
was immersed in a culture that honors
both making and crafts where people
perfect their craft over generations
it's a culture that masters both time
and space so that artists can truly
create with freedom and what I
discovered was a place I wasn't angry
with Tokyo hadn't wronged me in any way
I could no longer create with anger or
out of pain I had to bravely allow
myself to create from a different place
and what I found is this incredible tall
transcended a line on paper I found this
thing that connected my head to my heart
and my hand to everything I could see
the world in new ways
I found connections and corners and the
solutions to problems I never knew
existed it's like the world with always
positive and negative spaces could now
be seen and just by seeing it there was
no longer any fear it's like my pen was
a flashlight and the unknown was still
there but it wasn't scary after five
years of living in Japan and focusing on
my craft I felt like I needed a new
challenge so I moved to New York because
that's what you do as an artist right
you move to the greatest city in the
world has the ability to make you feel
completely and utterly invisible this is
when I began to truly ask myself who are
you I would wake up in the morning and
before I began my day I would meditate
on this and with this question in mind I
kept drawing
I followed the line I let it lead the
way the process of picking up a pen
something everyone has access to the act
of giving myself permission to let go of
all thoughts all fears
securities anything that would get in
the way of allowing myself to be
completely me that became my way of
experiencing freedom when I got to New
York I didn't want to play by the rules
of the art world I continued my practice
as an outsider I kept drawing curiosity
became the ink from my pen and I
continued to dive deeper over time I
began to create a bold confident space
for myself a space that was all my own
initially it was just my bedroom but
that bedroom ended up in the New York
Times and suddenly I was being seen and
known for this world I had to create it
since then I've created and collaborated
with some of the most unique artists
institutions and spaces from the screens
of Times Square to the New York City
Ballet for their incredible artist
series where I interviewed a number of
dancers their stories and words became
the foundation of over 30 drawings and
artworks which took over the promenade
walls windows and floors for a long time
I wanted to create a space for
contemplation and poetry and in 2019 I
was given the opportunity to do just
that by the trust of Governors Island
they provided me with the perfect canvas
in the form of a former military Chapel
meet the mailroom with drawings on the
exterior inspired by the history of the
island you walk inside you take your
shoes off and there's a drawing on the
floor in the form of a maze that brings
you back to you it's an invitation to
become calm and this allows you to see
phrases on the wall may you be wines may
you sleep soundly at night may we save
trees may you may you may we and these
phrases seem like they're rising from
you or falling into you
I've let my lines become much like a
language a language that has unfolded
much like life and when there has been
silence I've sought connection through
conversation asking questions to push
through the discomfort drawing has
taught me how to create my own walls it
has taught me to open my eyes and see
not only what is but what can be and
where there are broken systems we can
create new ones that actually function
and benefit all instead of just a select
few drawing has taught me how to fully
engage with the well and what I've come
to realize through this language of
lines it's not the importance of being
seen but rather the clifftop seeing that
we give to others and how true freedom
is the ability to see and I don't mean
that literally because sight is only one
way in which one can see but what I mean
is to experience the world in its
entirety maybe even more so during the
most challenging moments lay the one we
face today I'm Chantal Martin I draw and
I invite you to pick up a pen and see
where it takes you
[Music]